I'm Charles and I'm a radio producer now
I get to make coffee a proper Eddie
Christmas 2014 cook it or keep it two
turkeys could sage and onion two for the
slaughter and we saved these turkeys do
you want us to cook them or keep them we
open up this vote it absolutely exploded
Brian May from Queen B got involved in
the Daily Mail set it's disgusting they
thought that we would kill them live on
air the sound of turkeys being
slaughtered which was never going to
happen but sage and onion
were saved now they're happily clucking
- they clog the Gorger gobble gobble
they're gobbling is Radio dying you
can't eat now aren't you yes and no
there are loads more stations and people
are listening for for less time watch
the point of radio you know video killed
the radio star when you're driving what
you're listening to you're watching the
TV know you're listening to the radio
podcast possibly audiobooks or you're
listening to live radio fools prank
calls always fun cool up like local
brothels but with a character sorry no
no no pop the postman I know Pat the
postman I do like to pet a postman was
that a joke sorry I've got a big package
to deliver if you know what I mean oh
well you'll have to call in business
hours it's very small cut I stamp you
first-class I'm not a litter and lady
when I did it they would be as witty or
as audible as you are I was actually
told to [ __ ] off within I'd say 40
seconds
yeah that's not for me I'm gonna put it
out there this is a plug that hopefully
doesn't get edited out don't you edit
it's not ya told you I don't know Chris
Peter Joseph Turner I challenge you to
wrap up jack not this only the radio
station you conservatives Jack as you
want it could be the name we safely
I challenge you to a mineral water
mineral water and also the economic
climate of Germany if I my Germany okay
cool right break y'all kick it up
Jetfire I wanna pick up and change my
broken car tire and you may say Chris
how do you do that well I got a skill
the a mechanic got my nice deck pull it
out the garage slide it under like sand
smooth march slippery up you inflate the
tire so large I need the jacks here I
will go and follow Jill when I climb up
the hill like Jack and Jill J&J do it
every day not smoke a J yo cuz I like to
stay away getting jacked up like I got
my steroids
Jack popular name for the girls and the
boys will not the girls the first half
was a faux pas dear Ally yo I go back to
the top I fix it yeah I know I ought to
our ward my helpful daughter with some
mineral water I'll be like oh here's
some knowledge profound mineral water
just stealing from the ground why would
you do that I hope your enterprise fails
get in it filter through limestone and
shale for millions of years yes we get
it here give it to you and I'd be like
no idea coca-cola take it from the tap
they'd be like water and I'd be like no
taking back all their advertising the
world would not make me put the mineral
water in my mouth and swirl I take it
yes give it back to you I don't even
like the brand talk Belu you know they
don't know eat money to water aid but
I'm like thinking the lives that could
be saved if you just dissolve your
company and gave all the land in the
country to them you build it up yeah got
a knowledge on it I want to get some
rise in economics go over there the best
by far from a broken car to the German
period why MA how do I do it I tell you
all it's because my car was a DeLorean
here snug it up like a suture I travel
in time lie back to the future but they
had
horrible positions they were like not
like environmental emissions but they
were going down losing lots of money
like after war one it wasn't very funny
was it after World War one that it
started to collapse they were like oh no
we need to collect taxes and they had
too many notes over an inflation it was
so bad in the German nation some of
people get on stages and voted for
Hitler
I'd be like know why you're acting like
a temper he's just saying making Jew
scapegoats it's like no don't give that
Nazis your vote even though it's an
economic situation Ziya it's gone
deflated and flat like the car tire I'll
link it in wrap it up and go around end
it there with the mineral water flows
fast I could drop the mic but this is
all very valuable award Wow barking mmm
Meghan's campaign